hey we we going to watch the boys today
this is my frenchie impression 2x6
excited to check this episode out guys
make sure to
hit that subscribe button and click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever we got a reaction for the boys
up and you guys know how youtube works
can't show the whole thing so full
length uncut
watchalongs where you sync up with the
timecode will be available over at our
patreon page
we cover a lot of tv shows over there
and i really want to give a special
thanks to everyone
who has gone and shown their support to
us over at patreon
all these new changes with youtube
lately especially with
what is in the boys it has meant a hell
of a lot that you have gone and shown
your support at our patreon because
yeah they don't really let you monetize
much of these kind of
things anymore secondly i want to give a
special thank you to eric over at nerd
chronic for
editing these videos for us for youtube
and it's our watch alongs as well he had
us for people like movie trivia
schmodown a whole bunch of reactors
edited
for us in the past he edited my home
videos
that's a dumb joke let's just watch this
damn [ __ ]
[Music]
the golden girls i was alone in new york
turning tricks begging for the scraps
damn dude like just like blanche who you
think gave me company
thank you for being a friend so you're
betty white oh what a [ __ ] question
of course i'm betty white
yeah but she hasn't come after you but
that makes it so much worse
it means that she has some [ __ ] up
plan for me yeah i need this chip out
now i understand maybe you should just
put two and two together
maybe she saw you talking to him in
broad daylight
oh my god oh my god
going in blind huh oh it's fun
no oh no [ __ ]
i think you broke my head she goes
softer on the white guys
what do you want to do with him oh no
never mind the justice system just
doesn't
work anymore this is going to be gross
phone all the time it's like you can't
there's a security camera in the
background
oh you sick twisted [ __ ]
oh you sick
oh no gross
ah
that easy huh homelander
good for him oh my god
oh my god here comes a train
right here what's up buddy
i guess you don't need his help he's
gonna recruit
our lord and savior would you like a
fresco
[Applause]
what is it with the fresco i think it's
like
laced with drugs i hope so like deciding
scientology
don't get cool i never do
the past
that sound effect means we're
transitioning to the path
you're looking at 20 to 25 minimum or
you can come work for me
but even more so for sharia and jay i
believe
the other golden girls adx
florence adx the supermax that's where
all the really bad guys go
uh-oh she's from colorado what kind of
work do you do
putting together a team called the boys
so far i have two other boys
i'll let you surprise me wherever you
want
storm butt
oh oh my god
sam he's stimping for her oh
no oh no he feels abandoned
what a guy
oh wow he like likes her likes yeah yeah
he got feelings man
see i'm on your team look at me look at
me butcher
trust me i would love it if butcher's a
shot
oh jesus
with the security guard what's wrong
with him easy oh
jesus he murdered him [ __ ]
whoo
oh my god jesus
what the [ __ ]
is that the only byproduct
well i'm not doing any more of you
stupid pet tricks until i talk to my
sister
man
he's pyro now
oh jesus he is pyro now
lamplighter or lamplighter how do you
recognize that we love the mask
[ __ ] employer we have to kill him
across
first we gotta find out what the [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] is oh come on this is
literally an experimental soup facility
have you read a comic book frenchie oh
god
just don't open your eyes frenchy chill
oh he knows
oh god no no no no no no no no
no [ __ ] no school for a frenchie let's
see what happens
oh damn do you remember that extra
helping of crafts
shells and cheese that i snuck you now's
your chance of shooting frenchies
we ain't as friends boy the [ __ ] is it
oh no
oh incredible
let's get out of here you need her on
your team
no who is she i love her
cindy oh damn
so why don't we all just calm down and
live through this [ __ ]
oh jesus no
i mean it's what they deserve to be
quite honest
i'm gonna take my chances
[Applause]
goes on his own face oh hello marvin
oh bad oh bad no bad at least the vanish
oh poor guy butcher
you're right yeah fine
oh no buddy
it's what brings them together
embarrassed i wouldn't be late to a day
with homelander
i wouldn't have a date with homeland
she started fire
oh my god he overreacted are you
surprised
thought it was just the one trailer i
wanted to see how your meeting went
oh my god he's pathetically catching
fields yo
come on now why would you need to
explain anything to me
she was like maybe i made a mistake
that was what i was getting myself into
i think a train sabotaged me my entire
career
what we do think you're better than me
when i fantasize about
drowning me over
[Laughter]
a man in a seven-figure debt a heart
condition and in heavy withdrawal do you
really think you have the luxury to get
up and leave
everyone has the luxury to get up and
leave at any [ __ ] time they want
that's just the bottom line
i don't need your stress test all right
sabotage your own career
behavior wowie
oh
yeah mallory has a bit of he looks like
oliver queen
he does
uh-oh it's going to kill children
don't
and you just signed your deathborn this
is some kind of a scam
[Music]
if i wanted to boost some wheels it
wouldn't be a [ __ ] hyundai
[Laughter]
put it down whoa
she killed him oh he's he's bleeding
did you really
caught her eyes i got his head
oh
oh hell yeah how do you know
because it's a show and that's what they
normally do in tv shows
[Music]
you were supposed to be your boss
why didn't you stop me good question
huh odd oh french
are you froze up come on
take him to the hospital after all these
years man
does that lighter sink
don't you harm him what is that
is that a dick is that the guy the other
guy is a crazy dick
no it's not oh no hey
so welcome home brother charles it
totally is
oh my gosh no
no oh no
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's his [ __ ] dick don't be so
close minded
oh my god
how do you defeat this person what can
you possibly do
oh just stand in stormfront
oh jesus christ oh no oh my god they're
leaving us
oh jesus no
i do you were part of it and
this is our out i don't think it feels
good to move i don't know
you're kind of a monster as well why are
you looking at me like that
because it's pretty old you're a monster
revelation
for her tell butcher about a thick penis
around your neck
why isn't this man restrained no need i
wanted to come i don't want to hear a
single
goddamn word from you what i feel like
mallory's gonna get killed right now
oh you'd be doing me a favor why the
[ __ ] well i want to do that all you've
been doing is ending his torment
what exactly are you proposing
your grandmother
my daughter hmm
i was born in 1919
in berlin i am adolf hitler
[Laughter]
heinrich he was a lovely dancer
and that's gobbled oh god she's a nurse
this [ __ ] is crazy
we are in a war for the culture
wow other races are grinding us down
oh damn we can fight back
with an army of superman millions strong
except a train and you will be the man
who will lead us
wow he does look like the perfect nazis
he does neither of us has to be alone
ever again don't fall for it except for
when i go to see my social people
[Music]
oh jesus
[Music]
there's a golden girls song playing guys
no this is billy joel sarah boyd
directed this
wow the boys all right so this episode
was bookended
by homelander and stormfront
getting it on and then the arc
into getting it on
but with a deeper foundation then they
got it on the first time
wow starting up a race war you know it's
like i think we all sort of saw that
coming
in a sense with stormfront that seemed
to be pretty apparent that that's where
it was headed yeah
we got some more backstory she's really
old
yeah she's really old what she's 101 now
you know how
uh homelander was able to have this kid
who inherited the suit power
how come her kid wasn't able to inherit
that that's too bad it's a good question
poor little nazi child or not
she might not have been this way but man
those two having a kid
that'd be crazy homelanders is such a
such a child
man he's such a child i didn't know what
reaction he would
he would ultimately have but yeah no
makes sense he looks like the perfect
nazi boy
and he's easily seduced by power and by
status and by you know being admired
yeah
she said all the right things it's like
i was sitting there wondering like oh
maybe he'll turn maybe he'll make some
kind of unexpected flip because he's not
like a full-on race but no
no no he doesn't really care about
people at all doesn't he no
poor guy well not really
nah no poor man maybe a poor lamp
lighter but even
even then probably not oh god that was
crazy
i can't believe well let's have to see
the next it's crazy how the stakes
seem so contained and personal at the
beginning of the season
and now we're on the verge of a race war
i don't know how they wrap this up in
two episodes well they're green lit for
uh
season three already okay they even got
a prequel or spin-off happening too
right
yeah like what what the soups do when
they go to superheroes yeah
school or whatever so okay cool why not
um let's get going there but the real
heart of this episode
it seemed like what the central heart of
the episode was actually frenchie's
storyline
which was cool to have early on and
other reviews of this
of this series especially with season
two i think you and i have kind of been
on the same page of finding it a little
bit
not so impactful and a little bit
lackluster this time around they really
managed to
hey actually give them some real
backstory which not only gave a
backstory to him but give a backstory to
the early formation of the group between
mother's milk and butcher
and then this infusion of lamplighter
along the way is a pretty
if anyone has a clear-cut character arc
of this episode of tim he
has a whole dialogue the whole
explanation or even chemical was like
maybe maybe uh maybe i will kiss you now
mallory's here yeah now that you've
grown as a person
now that you're gonna let me go but yeah
that was a really good character i
thought what they did with this
character in this episode is probably me
yeah the best who's been the best who's
been
the whole series yeah the entire series
in terms of the writing and i liked how
they partitioned those things out
through the episode too and it's funny
because this season you know each time
i've had a complaint it usually seems
like the next episode it gets addressed
and i remember
kind of thinking like man it would be
nice to get some character on frenchie
at some point
lo and behold this episode kind of
proved to be that and i hope it's not
just building up to
like he's gonna die next time i feel
like he's gonna die because it seems
interesting
it seems like i feel like it'll be
mother's milk guys not
french oh no really but he has to get
home to his wife that's been his whole
motivation for two seasons
but i was i was really happy to see that
actor get something to work with who
plays frenchy because you know
i like him a lot and i feel like a lot
of my endearment towards frenchie has
been
the performer performer yeah and so like
to have some actual rich writing for him
was really nice
it helped make that repetitive storyline
they've been doing with him and gimmicko
suddenly feel earned yeah it makes sense
now because there was a point where it
was like i get it this is all you're
doing with him
yeah but then here you're like ah okay
yeah that whole backstory makes a lot
more sense i really like the contained
storyline that they had here of just
breaking in to this experimental
facility these test subjects you know
and it's it's a very
comic bookie like i haven't read the
boys comics but it
is a very comic book trope to have some
facility
like that whether you're containing all
your your soups here
or you're experimenting trying to figure
that in glass
yeah i do it in like literally almost
every comic book thing i've ever read
yeah yeah and uh but for what they're
doing it
it adds more weight to the bigger
development of what vaught is really all
about and then to the mystery of with
compound v
being out in the open what more they be
doing because yeah like what
uh lamplighter was talking about i
really do find it funny how
he's my my image would bob with him with
sean
ashmore ash moriah yeah my image with
him is so associated with iceman
and then they make him essentially pyro
here in this episode yeah
totally i thought he did a good job on
the performance side i thought he
brought a lot
to that character even though we've only
just met him and he only had a handful
of scenes and whatnot he left an
impression on me which i appreciated
well they set him up in a way where you
just think he's going to be full-on
villain uh he's just going to be a
baddie and then even the way his
dialogue was
progressing in the first half of this
episode god is you know the racist you
know like
you look like you could be but then you
see and you're like oh you okay so you
were at the height of
vaught fame for a while doing your movie
things and now you're like
even worse than a janitor yeah burning
yeah human evidence
sometimes an arc like that scene that he
had with mallory
i can probably sometimes feel a little
dismissive towards
however i think the fact that he didn't
rat them
out to stormfront made me go okay all
right you know what i will give him a
little chance we'll give him a little
chance he clearly wants a little bit of
a change and he wanted to die
yeah so you know so now he's why not
living you murdered some children
people do that every day who doesn't
murder kids you know he doesn't murder a
kid
the best of us in terms of that facility
storyline though i thought that was
really cool you're looking at all these
other soups
cindy am i right hey i'm excited for
cindy
yeah yeah it's just the ultimate power
that's the ultimate power how can you
defeat that i mean stormfront just
showed up
but i feel like if you she was like
poorly timed with that yeah oh man what
a badass
but the whole thing with the gotta watch
the words here
because youtube's been extra strict
apparently these days
but with the extra sausage going around
oh my gosh
and it's funny because you know like
tentacle
power ability when you're looking at the
security cam footage that's all i
thought it was and that's what i thought
it was original
i think it's when you said it yeah you
said what is that
and then oh no it's
the member it's like those giant worms
it feels like a lovecraftian thing and
then suddenly you're like no it's not
it's got one eye we need all the all the
different like metaphorical
that was so funny yeah yeah i mean it
makes me wonder
what the purpose of that power like i
know
what it remember well because i thought
it was interesting because it did
it's interesting to me be that you know
you see a lot of superhero things now
kind of cross-pollinating because part
way through
the hospital sequence they said
something about like we're trying to
stabilize compound v you know and on
adults
uh you know you might get a good power
you might get a crap power you might
explode and i was like
this is project powers yeah and so but i
do appreciate
the just you know level of integration
they put it with
this world you know i mean it's not the
most original idea
hiding inside of this mystery compound
but it did make for
both fun in terms of what other messed
up
powers in the world of the boys might
exist and also it made for yeah a pretty
tense you know set piece for them to all
get some info out but also
introduce new character etc i wish we
had seen
this compound before this episode
i know it's mentioned briefly in that
email but i feel like
this is such a big deal it could have
been like hinted at before
or now i feel like it's just a big plot
point
look uh suddenly there's this thing that
no one in the seven knows about not even
homelander
so you kind of feel like it was a little
left field there could have been more of
a little bit more of an extra build yeah
to like what is this thing maybe it's
the way because they're shorter epis
like there's not as many in a season i
don't know but it feels like it could
have been more
instead of oh here you go here's this
place that yeah i guess
these people and i guess yeah i i think
maybe i don't know if
if it has anything to do with this but i
did find myself surprised that you know
the metaphorical poop hit the fan so
quickly
upon arrival like i didn't expect things
to pop off kind of
upon entry yeah yeah so on the one hand
i'm still chewing on that because on the
one hand i'm like oh
maybe props for just going for it and
not over stretching it but i can also
kind of see where you're coming from too
so i'm jury out on that at first i was
kind of questioning
why stormfront has so much like power in
the situation
like why she's the only one who knows
about this but if she had a relationship
with
the man who created it in the first
place
and why she's able to walk around and do
things that are obviously
counterproductive to vots marketing at
the very least you know
yeah it makes sense that she has some
kind of status-based immunity almost and
it seems like she
that's not just an act now all that
stuff about like making fun
of the fame side of being a soup now it
seems like there's a genuine
place that she was coming from even that
scene that she had with storm uh with
homelanders she seemed like she was
being very sincere
i think this is the first time we've
seen her afraid there were instances
where i was like oh she's
she's clearly scared of him yeah yeah
and using
all the cunning she has to get him back
under the thumb yeah man
because even though she's like way
smarter than he is he is
dangerous partly because he's so
volatile it's so thick
that storyline that they had there with
butcher and
starlight and huey i like getting some
actual scenes and interactions between
starlight
and butcher uh specifically i know
[ __ ] kids where's lampard where's
lampwork there's lamplight
lamplighter when you need him
could have done some good in this
in that storyline with uh butcher
huey being knocked out and starlight
i mean there's been such a build up to
having a
some type of dynamic actually forming
between starlight and butcher
because he was always like no man no no
just she's all right she's cool
that's cool i like their scenes and
their interaction together and i wonder
if there's gonna be
any weight to the character of starlight
of murdering that guy just okay
get in the car drive off it's fine like
it's like murdering that innocent person
there's something kind of rubbed me the
wrong way on that because i know that
you know the boys are they're good guys
but they're also like anti-heroes in a
lot of ways they're not like
super good guys but they're still the
heroes and
and at the end of the day that that guy
was truly an innocent human being
because of family she could have been
like i'm starlight don't you recognize
me
like we need to get out of here this
guy's like she could have used that to
her advantage
what i'm saying is i don't think the
show didn't do anything to represent a
gray area here like she had this
dialogue with butcher where she was
explaining the way she feels about it
and i and i got it them having a bit of
a mutual respect because that's kind of
the mentality butcher would have
that makes sense to me and the way she's
evolved into the kind of character she
is
that makes sense to me but it also made
me feel like whoa starter you just kind
of seem like a really cold-hearted
person now
you know i couldn't tell in the editing
of that scene if they were trying to
imply that like she was trying to stop
him and because the car was there and
there was power it turned into something
way more than she intended or if she
knew that was gonna happen and she
intended to blast him and just blasted
him too
i think it was an accident like it
seemed like she took it too further than
she wanted to
yeah but there is something maybe in in
that just
execution of the action maybe that
squashes some of that impact or
something
yeah fair enough we'll see how it plays
out i like the scenes with them i like
when they're making fun of huey together
and i even like the scene where they're
trying to calm the one guy down and
we're not sure if he's gonna freak out
on them or not with the shock wave and
all that stuff
i mean i was on that guy's side in so
many ways
it's funny to me how huey was the start
of the boys
the show and he is by far the least
interesting character
like he is quickly i'm like i don't mind
if you just have him knocked out for two
episodes and just go to a season finale
at this point let's start light and
butcher bond
let them have that i've i enjoyed
watching
them bond way more in the hospital than
them bonding overweight being like
finicky and stuff like i liked chewy's
moments in the last episode but this was
like really gripping and the dynamics of
starlight and butcher
i thought were way more engaging than
starlight and huey at this point but the
stuff with the deep
and a train i still think a train is
going to end up helping out
starlight and huey it's going to happen
it's going to happen
i don't know i'm in the middle of you
both i'm like i don't know if he's gonna
help them but i don't know if he's gonna
do stuff for the seven either
like i don't know i think he's gonna be
pulled into the story line with the deep
in
this clear but once again you only have
two episodes
what the what the hell are you gonna do
what is it but that could continue i
mean like season one flowed pretty
straight into season three
and then they finished it immediately
with the exposing compound
that's true that's true but yeah it's
like
they've been doing such and like
whenever they cut to the stuff with the
deep
i do find that stuff really interesting
i want to kind of relish here and i want
to be here for a while
it's a really short part of each one of
these episodes
though now yeah getting to meet the the
leader and then that confrontation and
apparently the deep's resentment
feelings towards a train which
kind of came out of nowhere to me yeah i
was like what had ever
never associated a train at all for
sabotaging the way you did
i enjoyed that scene and i find it all
very
uh intriguing and clearly the deep is
also part of like it's one of those
groups where you try to recruit people
so he's clearly doing the re
you can't help you no never mind you
know like
he's doing his recruitment tactics i'm
curious to see where it goes but yeah
i'm kind of i'm
actually with you on well we've got so
many other things going on
right now we got a gazillion other
things going on and this is a little
thing that we're building
is this gonna pay off in the end or is
it gonna ultimately end in a way where
they're setting it up for something
bigger for season three i guess
that's where i would be leaning right
now because it is yeah
mostly to me it's very intriguing i like
the
you know commentary it's hinting at but
for a lot of this season at least it's
been mostly yeah
an excuse to do some comedy for the
episode to yeah introduce a more
humorous
aspect because the deep is such a
punchline character and he's so pathetic
yeah um so i could i could see this i
mean they're building up this alistar
guy and i'm sure that he is gonna
be a figure of some sort in this world i
wouldn't be surprised if he had that
kind of cracked open further in season
three perhaps
especially why he thinks he has such an
into the seven
yeah that i'm like you promising people
their spots back like they're
pretty much like what are you gonna do
and then
even though some of the jokes and the
social commentary
i really enjoy and it's that stuff that
i find clever
i think i've decided i really don't like
the character of maeve
i i don't i don't like her i think she's
a hypocrite i don't buy her motivation
i don't buy what is this releasing the
tape you look just as bad you look
just as bad since day one with this show
i feel like there was maybe a scene in
season one where she got like a slightly
cool moment
but i can't recall she has just seemed
like a weak
fragile character to me the way they've
written her
it's it's something where i'm like i
just don't care anymore i don't care
about you
there's nothing about your character
that i find really all
that redeeming i know she was she was
there as an emotional support at times
for
like she she's just a character who just
seems so damn emotional but i never
really get the sense of
that's why you're on the s even like
even the deep as how horrible of a
person as he is
he occasionally has him over here like
that's pretty cool what you could do
though you know
how you've got this role yeah even he
has that but with her
the way they use her in this show i
don't find her character to be
clever intriguing smart she's just
really
she's just a sad person and that's all
she really is i care about her i don't
care about her motivation for this i
don't care about her motivation to
protect elena i don't care about
any of it okay this to me you're gonna
die
that's what this is telling me and it's
she made two dumb choices in this season
already
she has the call i i cannot get past
that how she had the
she she called elena in the middle of
the the
the conference room where the seven come
come together
and then she hides
the she hides the the most important
secret evidence that she wouldn't even
want elena to find
yeah next to
clearly this is where i keep that safe
keep it secret
elena who's like i need your phone she
bee lines to where
maeve keeps her phone and she just has
it
there who wouldn't want to look at this
and like look at how fascinating this
this piece of information is so crazy
yeah why are you looking me at me like
that are you
delusional i don't i i'm not a fan of
like like i said it's all the stuff that
they do around her character that i like
yeah i really feel like they could do
something to like they're using her
character for
uh commentary obviously on how we handle
lgbtq inclusion but
at the same time i feel like they could
make more of an impact with that
character
by truly subverting the fact that often
characters in that position like bi and
lesbian characters are just not
often given real characters on tv as
much as i admire a lot of the periphery
you know like you said i think if we got
some real
character stuff with her and yeah delved
into
her glory on the seven her downfall from
there etc like we get a pretty good
torture that for a lot of the other
members who are focal and for as much
attention
and as much importance as we placed on
her every time she pops back up
like i'm always like oh that's right
maeve yeah even though she is part of
in that first season the most horrific
event to me of that entire season
she's built up as number two she's she's
number two on the seventh
but how there's nothing about her that's
likable to put her like plain and simple
i don't i can't tell you what's likable
about her
it seems like most of her character is
look she's got this girlfriend she wants
to protect
yeah and we all understand that
motivation but again
it just turns them into less less
than full-fledged characters for me
she's just not something about it just
lacks a compelling layer
to me and every time she meets with
somebody like a train to like connive
i'm always like oh maybe this is it
maybe we're gonna
actually you know grow some spine and
really stand up and have an arc
this season and i'm so i'm still waiting
on it and now my my one hope is that
because i'm
complaining now they'll do it i'm hoping
like she's gonna do something freaking
awesome
maybe she's gonna do something right
like i take it all back there's so much
build up too like her
finally doing something that makes her
character seem a little cool
cause like right now i'm as much as yeah
like the whole thing could be better i
find elena more interesting than her
yeah
was i feel so bad for you babe is so
whiny
and like that's what i mean i'm just
like oh what did you find
out oh tell me now i'm like you're just
it's so
needy and whiny and you're supposed to
be the number two of the seven
throw up and i wanna make it clear i
actually don't think it's the actress at
all no
no it's not the actress i really think
it's the writing of me it's like they
know how to write female characters
like stormfront's really interesting
starlight's more intriguing than uh
freaking
uh maeve the latest words in the map
she's in a tough position i'm like i'm
worried for her yeah so they know how to
do it
i just yeah it's weird i'm not even
concerned if
homelander kills me my forward is gonna
kill elena
at this point i'm like i feel like maybe
might just get killed off and all this
will be for nothing
you know i i sure could not i mean i i
now that i'm sitting here thinking about
it i'm like elena's probably gotta die
and then maeve will become a character
yeah
hey that situation we are in
jesse t usher the guy plays a train you
see the guy in shaft
dude he's the guy in chat he's the guy
in the chat reboot
just so you say about the background
here and he's the guy in
shaft i'm trying to figure out oh damn
not bad i just remember that actor being
like oh is he he has to say he's the
usher as his last name
all right guys well ending on the
complaint
the boys the best everything else fi
like
uh if there's ten story lines in here
nine out of ten were pretty solid
all right well what'd you guys think of
this episode subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
make sure to check us out on patreon
last but not least patron of the day
shout out
back to the office to shout out victoria
huntley i know i keep making all these
jokes about you and your fiance
cosplaying
all right but i got another one i gotta
do
considering it's the boys with the
recent events of how the boys have
turned out
i think it's only fair that i suggest
that you and your fiance cosplay
you as stormfront
he as a train oh that's
right no homeland
drugs heroin let me relive that whole
scene
season one could laser you
hmm he can he can light your lamp
with liberty and uh
make you feel translucent i really
thought this joke would would go a lot
stronger further but now just just laser
each other's
well at all we can't say that word
man boobs pectoralis is going to be
monetized because of the language
oh really i mean family you gotta
friendly attention to the youtube stuff
man that's
bad are we age-restricted now
yeah did you hear about the new i read
the age restrictions thing yeah yeah
i've ever
been hit by a bunch of stuff yeah
victoria doom in the butt